welcome back to CBS this morning Stephen
Colbert puts his satirical spin on
headlines every day every night as host
of The Late Show you know that one of
the main targets of his humor is
President Trump in his administration
now Colbert is taking viewers inside and
animated administration for a satirical
look the White House in a new series
it's called our cartoon president our
cartoon president even has a theme song
Donald Trump is a president Donald Trump
is president no one is from the mockery
was talking about including members of
the media Democrats the administration
and of course the president and the
first family I'm just saying I'd love to
spend more time with the kids plus the
military pretty much runs the government
now I mean they don't even let me come
to meetings anymore you are a figurehead
so you must wave to the sick and dying I
guess you're right the people need my
folksy relatable presence sir the
advance team has Purell the victims and
moved the eights and nines to the front
no tens why did I even want this job oh
yeah Obama made fun of me once Stephen
Colbert is executive producer of our
cartoon president on Showtime a division
of CBS welcome back yeah I think I've
been working on it for a while yeah so
every night you get a chance to talk
about the president and what's happening
in news and all that so why do a cartoon
series well because there's still more
to say there's all the things that
happen when the camera isn't pointed at
him there's everything that we hear
about happening in the White House but
we never get to see and we're so honored
here you know at the team on our cartoon
president that they allowed in our
cartoon cameras it's really it's it's
the first cartoon documentary of White
House ever and it's it's groundbreaking
and and how did the idea come for you we
had my director of animation at the Late
Show who also was at the old Colbert
Report his name is Tim Lukey and he came
up working with Adobe they had a new
program that they hadn't released yet
but they gave to us well you could do
real-time animation so I could actually
interview the president sitting the seat
next to me
and we did it on our live shows there
was you know there was that was not
pre-prepared and after we did a few
times he came up with everybody in the
white house he came up with basically a
wireframe animated puppets everyone and
he and Matt lap and one of my producers
said I think this could be a show and we
took it to Showtime and they said yeah
that looks like a show so we wrote it no
that's how we don't mean that's the
thing the writing is so good they've got
great lines like I love you dad his sons
are saying he goes I love me too
now this is a thing that's based on a
true story yeah that is a true story
yeah he really loves himself but Steven
this is the thing half the country is
gonna think it's great yes another half
is gonna be very very angry and upset
with you I don't know I don't know
that's true I might think so some people
might be think we're being too nice to
the president some people might think
we're being too hard on the president
but I think that there's a there's a big
chunk of the middle of the country
that's gonna enjoy seeing the curtain
pulled back I mean it's really it's not
it's not jokes on what he said or did
today
yeah cuz I picked that Bush every day
there's not a berry left on that Bush
but that time I'm done with my monologue
every day this is relationship comedy
this is like this is a workplace comedy
it's the office
you know but oval no no it's very well
done I'm thinking you're he's never
gonna come on your show after seeing
this he's not I think he will I bet I
would bet you on that oh really which
one about ten dollars ten dollars yeah
never coming on your show you're not
gonna be invited to a state dinner and
I'm wondering that might be the state
meal you're not gonna be invited to a
state dinner and I'm wondering are you
concerned about how this is going to
open the door against you by so many
different people what it's so pointed it
is so it listen it's very my girls
cartoon is gonna say something I haven't
said on my show what is it I have not
said yet oh there's a couple of things
that really yeah tell that to the FCC
but you had worked in cartoons before
right yeah yeah the ambiguously gay duo
with Robert Smigel it's Saturday Night
Live I'm ace everything big as they do
oh hold onto my belt buckle friend of
friends
[Laughter]
that's it yeah that's right oh yeah oh
yeah sure yeah they had the comic books
yeah and also cartoons are a big part I
mean in American history presidents have
been lampooned by cartoonists too so
you're sure I think of myself as a
modern Thomas Nast exactly examinee
Tigers right Steven you said something
really interesting all kidding aside
with with Oprah recently you two did an
interview and I was very struck by how
you described your show you said listen
I you know by the time the viewers come
they know what's happened during the day
and I'm just putting it in perspective
and want to give them something to laugh
because when you can laugh you can think
that's right and I think because when
you're afraid you said you can't think I
thought that was a very point at where
you put put it about what you do well
I'm kind of stealing that from Frank
Herbert in dune one of the lessons of
dune is and John sure knows he's a
science-fiction fan is that fear is the
mind killer yeah but as my mom used to
say you can't laugh and be afraid at the
same time so if you can laugh then you
can think and and we've got to think our
ways out of this because we felt our way
into this problem with fear and anger
but if we can laugh you can think our
way into I think we can think our way
into being an American community again
which is what laughter allows you to do
that's that's what we want to do every
night on the show is that it's a group
of people who had this experience
watching or paying attention to the news
that day and then we come together and
we laugh about it and that gives you a
sense that you're not crazy that other
people might be seeing the world the
same way you do
well John Dickerson be making an
appearance on the cartoon president all
of you will eventually make an
appearance in the cartoon president
we've actually I think we already have
art on there you are forehead you
couldn't put an ad for a personal injury
lawyer on that forehead oh god you're
are you mad at you have lower back pain
Paul Cole Wilson Johnson and forehead
is it really that big ships buy that in
case the ocean levels actually rise
they'll still be some forehead above
above the way you're supposed to seek
higher ground
that's not everybody can gather alright
I was pretty cute thank you I'll tell
the artist it's fun watching you watch
Elon Musk yes I know really Joe be
excited how yeah exactly and it's not
just that you know he's the Falcon Heavy
went up but the tandem rocket I think
that's the future we were promised as a
child
yes landing on the fins like ballet and
then the damn car in space I showed it
to my 16 year old when I got home that
night he hadn't actually seen the
footage of the car yet and he like
jumped up and he goes oh my gosh in all
he's read a lot of science fiction to
those and all the science fiction I've
read nowhere did anyone even the Golden
Age of science fiction imagined that the
future would have something so
light-hearted that was so inspiring at
the same time that an ordinary object in
space would make it seem like it's
natural for us to be up there it's right
he's silly and fun things are important
yeah exactly I agree
cartoon president silly and fun Thank
You Stephen Colbert thank you watch the
premiere of our cartoon president Donald
Trump is the president's theme song very
catchy Sunday night on Showtime and
catch the Late Show with Stephen Colbert
hey he's on tonight 11:35 10:35 central
right here on CBS